او التيار الكهربائي في هذه المدينه بشكل
مؤقت هناك انقطاعات ولكن الى حد الان
تستمر اسلحات سنؤمن ايصال الكهربائي في
اقصر وقت ممكن بشكل دائم
وزعنا 34 الف محطه لاسلكيه من اجل تامين
الانترنت والاتصالات في هذه المدينه
ونستمر في تشخيص الاضرار الجسيمه منها
والخفيفه ولكن نحتاج ايضا الى ازاله كل
الاركان والانقراض الموجوده في هذه
المدينه وبعد
انتهاء الهزات الاعتداديه قدر الامكان
سنعيد اعمار هذه المدينه
لدينا اكثر من 400 خبير في منهم مهندسين
جيولوجين ومنهم مهندسين
اعمارهم جميعا يعملون هنا الان في تشخيص
كل الاضرار ومن خلال
حاله منزلي هم هل هي منهاره سببا هل لديها
اضرار جسيما لا يمكنها الدخول او لديها
اضرار بسيطه يمكن
اصلاحها والعوده اليها او ليس لديها اي
اضرار يعني الجميع بامكانها ان يحصل على
هذه المعلومات من خلال موقع الدوله
الالكترونيه وادخال ارقامهم الوطنيه فقط
طبعا الى ذلك الحين يجب ان ندخل الى اي
مبنى ابدا حتى ولو كان يبدو سليم بالتالي
يجب على الجميع ان ينتظر النتائج
والاعلانات النهائيه التي سننشرها في
الموقع التابع للحكومه عبر الدوله
الالكترونيه طبعا الى جانب ذلك سنستمر
بشكل سريع ومستمر
اخبار المواطنين عن المستجدات وايضا
لتامين احتياجاتهم لدينا مكاتب في الميدان
ممثليات في الميدان في مركز المدينه
وايضا في نوردا وفي اصلاحه لدينا مكاتب
صغيره هناك
اللي تشخيص الاضرار وايضا لتلبيه
الاحتياجات بامكان المواطن ان يلجاوا الى
هناك ايضا في حل احتياجات او في حال
يريدون معرفه ما هي حال منازلهم او
المباني السكريه التي كانوا يقتلونها طبعا
ننسق مع
رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان من اجل عوده
الحياه الى طبيعتها في اقصر وقتا ممكن
طبعا نحن في ازمير في فان في في المدن
الاخرى استطعنا ان نعيد الاعمار في فتره
قصيره جدا وهنا ايضا سنتخذ هذه الخطوات
لاعاده الاعمال واعاده الحياه الى طبيعتها
في اقصر وقت ممكن
سنعيد المواطنين الى منازلهم الدائمه
بوقتا في وقت قصير
سنعمل بشكل متزامن مع كل المدن وايضا
سنععلن التعاون الشامل في العشر المدن
لاعاده الاعمار في العشر المدن التي تضررت
من هذا الزلزال او هذين الزلزلين والهزات
الارتداديه الاخرى طبعا ستكون هناك
سيكون هناك عدد عمال يقرب عددهم من 30,000
وايضا كل الذين يستمرون الان في رفع
الانقاض ستساهم في رفع الركام وازاله
انقاذ هنا
سيتم ايضا العمل معهم على اعاده الاعمار
في هذه المدن وطبعا ستنسق عمليه اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد في هذه
المنطقه ايضا في العمل على كل هذه
المشاريع طبعا بعد ذلك في اعاده اعمار هذه
المنطقه سيتم دراسه القاعده
السطح الذي سنبني عليه هذه ما نزلنا تم في
كل دقيقه لذلك نحن
سنتسارع في هذه العمليه ونؤمن كلها
الاحتياجات
لا احد يمكنه ان يفهم
ما هي حاله المواطنين الذين يعانون هنا من
من البرد ولديهم ازمه نفسيه كبيره الان
نحن نتفهم هذه الحاله ولذلك سنسارع في
دعوه الشركات ايضا التي
تساهم في بناء هذه المنازل الدائمه
والمباني الدائمه هنا
اشكر كل الفراق التي تعمل
دون ملل
ودون نوم لا احد
ياخذ قسط من الراحه او او حتى قسم الراحه
لتناول بعض الماكولات او للحساء الساخن او
اشاء الساخن
نحن نشكر كل من يساهم ويقدم كل ما بوسعه
من اجل انقاذ العالقين هنا تحت الانقاذ
اشكر قوات الامن
وقوات الدرك وايضا كل الفرق فرق الانقاذ
والمتطوعين ونشكر المواطنين ايضا الضحايا
او الذين
هذا الزلزال ولهذه الكارثه والذين نجوا
منها اشكرهم على صبرهم لانهم تركوا كل هذه
الالام وبداوا بمساعده الفرق لانقاذ
معارفهم لانقاذ الجيران لانقاذ الناس
الاخرين العالقين تحت الانقاد كل ما
سمعناه منهم ان يبقى
لتبقى الدوله قويه وليتحد الشعب ونحن
جميعا سنتغلب على هذه المصاعب هذه الجمل
كانت مؤثره جدا
والههمتنا القوه وبالتالي نحن وباذن الله
تعالى سنتغلب على كل التحديات التي نتجت
عن هذه الكارثه وباذن الله تعالى ان نعيد
اعمار هذه المدن وسنعمر مدينه
قصبه هي من جديد ومركز غازي عنتاب من جديد
وبالتالي
سنستمر في هذه العمليات ونبدا بعدد
الاعمار في اقصر وقت ممكن كما تعلمون الان
خلال يومين استطعنا ان نعيد الاهالي الى
اماكن اقامه مؤقته والان بامكاننا ان نعبر
هذه المدينه في اقصر وقت ممكن وكما انشانا
هذه المنازل في الاماكن الاخرى التي تعرض
سنستمر هنا ايضا في العمل من اجل تقديم
هذه المنازل
للمواطنين
وسنستمر بتقديم المعلومات من هنا كل ساعه
تقريبا لاخواننا المتضررين من هذا الزلزال
وطبعا لاشاب تركيا الذي يتابع انكتب ما
يحصل هنا
اترحموا على ارواح من توفي في هذه الزلازل
مره اخرى واتمنى الشفاء العاجل للجرحى
شكرا جزيلا